et vous voyez la pâte elle se répartit
toute seule autour de votre de votre
douille voilà stop
magnifique je me lâche pour les je vous
lâche pour cette ligne précision et
douceur ce sont les impératifs pour
réussir des macarons fait maison cet
après-midi Carine solofiev pâtissière et
cuisinière de profession donne un cours
dans son école le cuisinaire du roi le
principe c'est de préparer tout de A à Z
donc les gens arrivent tout est prêt et
je vais les guider pas à pas pour
préparer à la fois les coques de macaron
et la garniture au menu macarons parfum
ganache chocolat au lait et confit de
framboises pour les réaliser plusieurs
étapes sont à respecter donc là une fois
que c'est on met au four
et puis à la sortie du four on laisse
refroidir on récupère et puis on va
garnir avec les préparations qu'on a
faites donc la ganache et puis un confit
de framboise
[Musique]
fin de l'atelier de cuisine au bout de
deux heures de préparation les
participants emportent avec une dizaine
de macarons un retour d'expérience très
positif elle a beaucoup faire le gâteau
à la maison on leur fait beaucoup et
donc je trouve que c'est bien prendre
avec un professionnel c'est plutôt bien
j'adore la pâtisserie et j'avais envie
d'essayer les macarons et je trouvais
que cet atelier
et franchement je trouve ça formidable
pour les passionnés de cuisine ou de
pâtisserie les cours sont ouverts toute
l'année à partir de 12 ans
[Musique]